If you find yourself loving someone who is no good for you, do a little self-examination.
If you find that your relationship is toxic, accept it for what it is:...
...attraction, not love.
People in toxic relationships are looking for a partner in crime;...
...someone to join them in their path to destruction.
Maybe, for example, you find someone who has some of the same self-esteem issues as you do...
...or emotional challenges as you.
Together you each have someone to share your misery with, a mate to complain to and complain about.
These are relationships based on a toxic attraction and they should not be confused with love relationships of any kind.
Love is a very different process...
...and has nothing to do with finding a partner to share your unhealthy patterns.
Real love is able to transcend those patterns.